Somalians
ripped off that state for
billions of dollars. I don't want them
in our country. Their country is no good
for a reason.
Their country stinks
and we don't want them in our country.
[Music]
Just imagine the people back in the day
when they would have to travel certain
distances for months or even years. What
is one thing that they would carry with
them?
The Quran. Why? Because they did not
have it on their mobile devices or their
gadgets. Brothers and sisters, imagine
you have a app, the Qurani app, which
not only shows you how much rewards you
get, but reminds you to read the Quran,
gives you reminders. Download the Qurani
app now and let it testify for you on
Yawm al-Qiyamah that you read it
wherever you was. As-salamu alaykum wa
rahmatullahi wa barakatuh brothers and
sisters and dear friends, I'm here with
Dawood. Hamdulillah, a beautiful brother
who I've known when I first came to
Islam and he is here at the head of
distribution at Salam Salar Pro. So, if
any of your masa coming late, it's not
his fault. Hamdulillah, he's been
sending out thousands and thousands and
boxes and boxes. I am one now we're
sending you four boxes. Shout out to
Farooq. If you've run out, please let us
know. Inshallah, SQ. Let us know
Inshallah we're supplying all the da'wah
tables around the world with Salam
masks. Okay, let's get straight into it.
So,
Trump has come out. I haven't seen the
video. I've heard that he said some
stuff about the Somali community.
>> Yeah.
Obviously, I think he has a problem with
Ilhan Omar. And I think he's trying to
bring that into Inshallah, which is but
I don't think she represents the Somali
community.
Anyways, you know, if I might be honest
with you, with all due respect, the
Hamdulillah Somali community and what
they stand for and what they do, Ilhan
Omar is a a a disaster for them in those
specific aspects. So, let's get straight
into it. Let's watch. Have you seen the
video? Yeah. I haven't. So, let's watch
Inshallah.
Somalians
ripped off that state for
billions of dollars. Billions.
Every year,
billions of dollars
and they contribute nothing.
Is he talking about Israel?
What was it What was it, bro? Is he
talking about Israel? That's literally
the
>> it What was it, Billy? It's the billions
and they have a country with nothing. Is
he talking about Israel? Yeah. That's
literally the
>> I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm
I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm
I'm I'm
Was he talking about Israel before he
spoke about Somalia? Is this what's
going on?
That's what people are saying.
Yeah, okay. Okay.
The welfare is like 88%.
They contribute nothing.
I don't want them in our country. I'll
be honest with you, okay? Some of you
say, "Oh, that's not politically
correct." I don't care. Yeah, it wasn't
88 because we want to correct as well,
Mr. President Trump. From cuz I watched
reports about this. It's apparently it's
45% of like people who are on welfare,
but then even that I don't know how true
it is, but 88%
>> Okay, but with all due respect, man,
look what's going on in your country,
man. You've got drug addicts on the road
like zombies, homelessness,
gambling addiction, alcohol addiction.
>> Absolutely. Pedophilia. In fact, in
fact,
the Epstein files. Exactly. But like In
fact, the the the the Somali community,
especially in Minnesota, they're
actually known to own businesses. So,
they're very hard working people. They
build businesses. Yeah. Um in Minnesota
and and elsewhere. Yeah, exactly. That's
that's that's really true, Subhanallah.
Um and yeah, he I mean, he's talking
about all this kind of stuff. Um with
all due respect, if there's anyone
that's causing when it comes to
pedophiles and this that, it's it's the
Israel like let's be honest, the
Zionists. Zionists who were There was
one guy who was actually I don't know
what he position he held high in Israel.
He was trying to meet up with a young
boy or a girl. Mhm.
Bro, get sent back straight away. No,
nothing. You know, with all due respect,
Epstein Island was was it run by Was he
doing that in in the US?
>> Yes. Bro, in the US, bro, you get
shipped back. And it's it's the right to
return. So, the it's become a safe haven
for pedophiles in America. They're
running back to the right to return of
Israel. Okay, are they Somalis? No,
they're not. Epstein Island, was he Was
he Epstein Somali? Yes.
What's her name? Maxwell. Um she just
Ghislaine.
>> Just Ghislaine Maxwell. Her father,
Robert Maxwell. Okay, so para is Are
they Somalis running these rings
blackmailing politicians like yourself?
You might be on that list. Are they
Somali? No, they're not. So, if there's
anyone that's harming your country, it's
not the Somalis. Let's carry on. I don't
want them in our country. Their country
is no good for a reason.
Their country stinks
and we don't want them in our country.
Now, that's really
I think Have you know what? I think
Trump is getting old cuz he he just
reminded me of an old person that's kind
of losing their marbles there and I'm
not wanting to be disrespectful, but he
seems I think he's just someone just
over overconfident. And he he he just
seems like a stupid guy. He's a funny
guy. Look, I just want to say he's just
a comedian. I see him like a comedian
who's running the country. That's what I
see him as, yeah. And actually, he's not
running the country. There's people
behind him who's running the country and
that's Israel. Yeah. No, yes, they're
putting the strength. Candace Owens and
the rest are coming out with it. So, I
mean, look,
if as a president,
there's criticism in what you say and
there's truth to it,
I just feel like the way he's just done
it, there's a really poor taste, very
very very poor taste.
Of course, of course.
Let's carry on watching. I can say that
about other countries, too.
I can say it about other countries, too.
We don't want them to hell. We got to
We have to rebuild our country. You
know, our country is at a tipping point.
We could go bad. We're at a tipping
point. I don't know if people mind me
saying that, but I'm saying it.
Uh we could go one way or the other
and we're going to go the wrong way if
we keep taking in garbage into our
country.
Ilhan Omar is garbage. She's garbage.
Her friends are garbage. These aren't
people that work. These aren't people
that say, "Let's go. Come on. Let's make
this place great." These are people that
do nothing but complain.
They complain. So, you see,
these are people who do nothing but
complaining. So, you said it so well at
the beginning. Um if you have political
issues with a person, that's fine. I
mean, call them out like he's calling
her out.
But then to use that to attack an entire
community,
that really reminds me of like Nazi
Germany. I'm I'm going to have to say
that. You are the president of of the
United States. You have immense power
and you're lying is
I'm not going to It is a compulsive
liar, but that's one of the signs of the
hour. People are believing They will
believe lies. You're you're saying
things that when I watched the report
about
what's actually happening in Minnesota.
And this is the thing.
During lockdown,
there was not there was countless of
communities in the US who were found out
to use
um what's it called? Lockdown to do
fraud.
>> Yeah.
In fact, there were
Yeah, there was institutions
institutions, you know,
who were using in this country, you
know, I mean, like if you want to be
There was a woman who selling PPE. Yeah.
You know, she got found out. 30 million
dollars.
One woman.
Okay? She got found out because she was
cool with like she was winning these
contracts because she was cool with
people who were giving out these dishing
out these contracts. So, we can see here
it's nothing to do with being Somali. If
there was a group and I watched this
there was this segment I was watching
where journalists they went into this
um
community in Minnesota and they were
asking people about this very thing. And
they said, "Look,
what happened here? Like these are the
allegations. These Some people got
charged with like fraud and things." And
there was this one Somali uncle he said,
"Look,
I've been in this country for 25 years.
I've worked very very hard. You know, if
there are individuals within our
community who are doing this, that's
fine. Call them out. But you can't say
brush off every single one of us who
work very very hard. And let me tell you
something about Somalis, yeah.
One, we're going to go through some of
the memes cuz I feel like it's the
funniest things I've seen in my life.
Incredible memes. Second, Somalis are a
super super super intelligent community,
you know? Jews usually do really well in
school.
Poetry is one of the things in their
culture that they they heal very you
know, they're like excellent poets. The
poets of Africa.
>> Quran, they known for Quran. Quran,
they're known They have known for the
Quran, Hamdulillah.
My wife always tells me this. She says
that and by the way, my wife is not
Somali. Yeah. She says cuz she grew up
in Northwest London.
And she says that the only time she
started to see hijabs Yeah. in
Islamic identification was when the
Somalis started to come in. Yeah. She
says that the Somali sisters were the
ones who made it like acceptable for
others to start wearing the hijab cuz
when she grew up And that's that da'wah.
Yeah. Yeah, that's physical da'wah
da'wah. Cuz my my wife she she comes
from Algeria. She grew up around a lot
of Muslims when they were not wearing
hijab. It's when the Somalis started to
come in
that So, they're very proud people, but
they're also very
smart and Yeah. in a way they integrate
themselves, you know?
So, Yeah, they do they do they look
after each other as well and also for
example, the Quran is a massive thing to
me, yeah? And we judge people from the
akhirah. We don't judge This is more on
Trump and this this that. Brother, who
cares? When you're talking about the
dunya and and even that is a lie. You're
talking about lies about that. Number
one, number two, one thing that I admire
about the Somali community is how they
treat the divorcees. They don't have the
stigma. Yes, like Somali when you
divorce, it's not like, "Oh, you're an
issue."
>> Really?
>> No, no. Bro, no, no. Brother, let me
tell you something. That's one thing
that I admire about them cuz there's a
specific one specific Somali singer
she's a woman. She's been married eight
times. There's no There's no stigma on
her. Like how many people I come and see
her? There's no stigma on her. There's
no like, "Oh, you're Do you get what I'm
saying?" She's a so-called guru or
something like that. You hit the road or
something like that. She's thinking
about her ex or something like that.
>> you know where that comes from? It's
just
>> know, but I I admire it because the
thing is there's no stigma like in the
Asian community, yeah? Not all of them,
yeah? But there's this "Oh, you're
divorced. You're finished." And
Look, I'll be I'll be honest with you.
I'm being I'm not here I'm just real.
Okay, there are some communities where
they really took down on divorces and
that is I'm so sorry that's not Islam.
Yeah. They don't. They're like, "Okay,
you divorced her, no problem." It's not
a big deal. Do you know what I'm trying
to say? Yeah.
Somali food is so underrated, bro. Now
it's kicking off. Yeah,
and other contributions to that as well.
Brothers restaurant, every time I go
there and that video went viral. Yeah,
Somali food is so underrated, okay?
Alhamdulillah. And they have so much
more like you said about the hijab, the
woman with a hijab, etc. Alhamdulillah.
So, there's so much good and we look at
it from an akhira perspective. So, yeah,
let's carry on. Let's do this.
>> Yeah.
And from where they came from, they got
nothing.
You know, if they came from paradise,
they said, "This isn't paradise." But
when they come from hell
and they complain
and do nothing but Well, I use you
Do you use the word Yeah, he goes
they they they mean they No way,
you a president used that that language.
Yeah, well it's it's about number one,
you're if anyone's from hell, it's you.
If anyone Let me tell you your actions
are pure. Look, you you know Fyre Fest,
Epstein Island, yeah? If anyone's from
hell, it's you. If anyone put the
actions of paradise or people who are
the Quran, etc., is is the Somali
people. Let's put it that Let's carry
on. and do nothing but
We don't want them in our country. Let
them go back to where they came from and
fix it. That sounds very personal.
>> bro. You can see though you can see he's
got this issue with Ilhan Omar. Yeah.
And he is basically going for the Somali
community. That's what he's doing, yeah?
And my friend, if you didn't go and
invade these countries, nobody wants to
come to your flipping lands, with all
due respect. Okay? You can see what
you're doing around the world. So, to me
it's it's it's a it's it's
I mean, look, you can't take this guy
I'll be honest you can't take this guy
seriously. I can't It's not someone
that's sane for me to come and say you
know you have someone that's
psychologically unwell. Yeah. If he
comes and hits me, I can't take him
seriously. Okay, bro. Okay,
it's okay. It's okay. You have to treat
him like that. He's like someone that's
not mentally well.
>> Yeah. So, let's go to some
>> think he's getting old. I think that's
what it is.
I'm not excusing him. I'm just saying
he's not mentally well, bro. Yeah. Let's
go to some memes. So, there were some
memes that were done that is actually
hilarious. So,
what I'm going to do is inshallah I'm
going to get you guys to play that
towards the end. But any last words?
Yeah, of course. Um I wanted to say
this, yeah. I think and cuz I watched
cuz obviously, you know, clearly I'm not
Somali and I remember we made a video a
couple years ago when we talking about
and they were like one of the critiques
we know it was
someone that was said about and a lot of
people were saying, "Look, why didn't
you bring a Somali to speak?" You know?
And one of the things I really liked
about the segment I was watching where
the guy went into Minnesota
he was saying that when he was going to
the mall
he was seeing Somali flags
and um he would see
Palestinian flags.
You know?
And
if there's one thing that I know about
Somalis and I know it it may not
sometimes be as apparent
but like Somali people like what
is very remarkable about them is that
I have been able to see such a beautiful
transformation
that you know, this idea that
they're not contributing or they're not
like wanting to be part of society or
like in the UK for example like
the schools that our kids go to, you
know, the amount of Somali
like sisters who are becoming teachers
and have been
positive role models, you know, the
amount of like
um Somalis that are doing their PhDs
here and becoming doctors and all of
these things like
I just find it so distasteful um for as
someone as a leader of a country
that is trying to stigmatize stig-
stigmatize a group of people who are
saying, "Look, yes, we do understand. We
know exactly where we come from. In
fact, we can tell you
six generations from from where we who
our granddad was. We know who we are.
We're very proud people, but we are also
people who here who've come here. We
fled Somalia
and we here and we want to contribute.
The majority of us want to do good." And
they contribute and there's bad people
in every community, with all due
respect. You can't talk about the gang
violence and guidance for that. It's
It's happens with every community. I'm
so sorry. I'm I'm curious from Turkey.
The the Turkish mafia who's
bringing in heroin Yeah. and all this
kind of polluting with all due respect.
You can't There's good and bad in
everywhere. So, I mean that's it. That's
what we can say, inshallah. So, and even
like one thing that you might come and
say, "Come on, where where do we know
the thing from? Well, I be lying to
lie." Mhm. But it's Somalis, with all
due respect, man. It's It's And this one
scholar said, he said, "I'd rather a
Muslim lie
and he's saying, "Wallahi billahi
wallahi billahi"
>> Subhanallah. rather than him tell the
truth and he's swearing by the oath of
another god." Subhanallah. Yeah, he
said, "I'd rather." Yeah, not that I'm
saying Somalis I'm saying and I I tell
you when someone people come to me and
say Mhm. Ali, you know, you've got to
where the wallahi wallahi, yeah? I'm
like So, sometimes I
Somali teachers or brothers, etc. where
But the point is what? There's so many
beautiful characters and guess what?
Those are things that matter cuz on
Trump with his Epstein Islands and this
that Mhm. You are from If anyone's from
hell, it's you. If you die in this
thing. And the people of Jannah, the
characters you can see it with the with
the with the carry this out, you know,
subhanallah, the Quran which is bro,
this is fundamental. Yes? To me, bro,
they are leading when it comes to the
kalam of Allah. So, to me, bro, with all
due respect, I mean Trump is an accident
He's a Trump. And also also, honestly,
this is an invitation to non-Somalis and
non-Muslims Yes.
You everyone that's been on TikTok the
last 2 years, you know that a lot of
Somali restaurants in London
gone viral. Yeah. And every single time
I'm in there Yes. I see non-Muslim
Everyone's in there. I see the guy
serving. They're always jokey. They're
always joking with you. They're always
friendly. Good people. Wallahi. So, for
any non-Muslim in Minnesota or elsewhere
where you find a Somali community, go
there. Speak to the speak
>> Bro, I'm not joking, yeah? I haven't I
haven't I haven't eaten all day, yeah?
Bro, should we go to Somali restaurant
after this? Brothers. I'm not joking.
You know why? The No, I was just
thinking I'm hungry, yeah? I was just
going I was going to
But but what I was going to say But I'm
not joking. Wallahi, you keep talking
about, yeah? I'm going to go cuz you
know I'm going to actually You know
what? Bro,
I haven't got I was going to call them.
You just ask I've got Hanif. Okay, bro.
Let's go Are you free?
Let's go eat together and then I'll drop
you home.
Okay.
>> Come on, bro. Me and you about this guy.
When you eat here, you get more hungry.
Big up big up the Somalis. Big up the
the African the American Somalis.
Brothers restaurant, Toronto. We're
coming, inshallah, in 1 hour. We'll be
about to Hanif, inshallah. You know,
everyone everyone in America
love give back love to the Somalis.
Beautiful community. Do not listen to
the people who want to divide Exactly.
and do all these things. And we'll come
to their defense, alhamdulillah, even if
this happened to the Bengalis or the
Pakistanis. I'm not for you to come and
generalize everyone. It's disgusting.
Uh till uh next time, inshallah.
Let's go, inshallah. One second.
As-salamu alaykum warahmatullah wa
barakatuh.